hey guys it's max today i'm super
excited to compare
apple's brand new m1 powered mac mini
against their previous
intel powered one this is the i7 6 core
model
that they in fact are still selling on
their website
and not only is this video going to be
very interesting because
this one the m1 has 16 gigs of ram the
max it can have
and this one has 64 gigabytes of ram
but i'm also tossing in an external
graphics card unit
this has a 5700 xd in it and only the
intel based ones
support egpus at least for now
this is gonna get a little bit crazy
we'll be taking a look at photo editing
logic xcode video editing gaming
performance and more both with and
without the egpu
and then i'm going to talk about some
differences between these two
systems now before we jump in let's talk
about prices
this mac mini right here believe it or
not costs
three thousand dollars if you just go
and pick it up from
apple whereas the m1 powered mac mini in
my hand
is 900. now of course
not everything is lined up right here
you'll see that this mac mini has a 2
terabyte ssd
this one has a base 256 gig and we're
gonna see this performance difference
which would be interesting
but along with that this mac mini the
ram 64 gigs came straight from apple
which they charged a lot of money for
and we also have 10 gigabit ethernet
which costs another 100
which you cannot get on this mac mini
which is a bummer for people that use
servers network attached storage things
like that
now along with that the intel mac minis
allow you to upgrade your ram
yourself and you can save a ton of money
so
if we match up these systems and we
upgrade our ram ourselves for only 250
dollars
get rid of that 10 gigabit ethernet and
match up 512 gigs of ssd
which is the lowest the i7 intel powered
mac mini can get you'll see that the
price difference
is much smaller it's still about 500
bucks more
to get the intel one and with the apple
one we are spending
a lot more per dollar for that extra
eight gigs of ram which now we have to
because it is
soldered in let's jump into performance
starting out with cinebench r23 which is
going to max out the cpus in these
systems
the great thing about this mac mini when
it came out is people love that six core
cpu it was a great deal and a small
system
and here we see that the overall score
isn't that different the m1 mac mini
is only eight percent faster than the
intel one so that's a very small
difference now what you don't see on
these charts
is the fan noise the intel mac mini
was running super loud the fan was maxed
out
whereas the m1 powered mac mini was
silent the fan was running at the lowest
speed it possibly can run
at and with that this cpu here was about
30
degrees cooler than this one with its
fans maxed
out now not only that there's also a
difference
in wattage this intel mac mini actually
spiked over 100 watts at the start of
the test for the cpu
and then settled in at about 75 watts
the apple powered mac mini was using
just
12.6 watts to achieve
this performance so although the
performance difference isn't that big
the amount of power used the amount of
heat that's output and the fan noise
differences are
massive the next test i tested was
geekbench 5 which runs a bunch of
different workloads
and as far as single core performance
the mac mini was
58 faster with a score of 1753
that score is absolutely insane
no other cpu even ones that cost
thousands of dollars can match
up and opening things up and daily use
tasks are incredibly fast
on the m1 powered macbook pro now as far
as multi-core performance
we have a difference of 32 percent
so with mixed workloads not 100 cpu
workloads like in cinebench
there is a much bigger difference now
let's get into
graphics performance my first test is
geekbench 5 using
metal and well you guys see the
difference right here it is
massive the m1 powered mac mini is more
than four and a half times
faster or four and a half times better
graphics performance and that is the
weakest link
of the intel powered mac minis which is
why a lot of people use
external graphics card units which we'll
talk about in just
a bit now i also tested opencl
which for apps have not yet been
optimized here the difference is smaller
but the mac mini
m1 powered one is still more than three
and a half times faster now of course
this is for compute type workloads so
what about
gaming performance we used gfx bench to
test out the bra
gaming performance between both of these
with metal optimized
games and once again as you can see the
difference is
shocking we're going from 13 frames per
second to 78
that is 5.8 times higher frames per
second for gaming
and you're going from a system that
really can't game
unless it's something very simple with
low graphics
to a system that can actually game and
with that it can game
silently instead of fan kicking up
fairly loud now before we get into
professional applications i wanted to
test out the ssd speeds because
as i mentioned we have a two terabyte
ssd in here the best one
and as you go up in the storage your
performance does get faster
where with the new m1 powered mac mini i
have the base 256 gigabyte option
for us we connect to external ssds an
external server over thunderbolt 3 so
that is
fine for us but looking at the
difference in speeds
as far as right the intel powered one is
faster and then as far as read the m1
powered
mac mini is faster now before if you
would get one of these
with the base uh storage or maybe even
the 512
it would be quite a bit slower in some
cases half the speed as far as ssd
so it's nice to see that even if you get
the base option you're still getting
really good ssd speeds with these new
mac minis now let's get into the pro
apps we're going to start out with logic
and we're running a benchmark called the
new logic pro
benchmark and the i7 powered mac mini
handled
76 tracks which is really good
much better than the previous lower end
macbook pros those handled
less than 10. now the new m1 powered mac
mini
handled 90 tracks and keep in mind we
have a big difference in ram
as well so not only did it handle about
18
more tracks but it ran silent compared
to this one
running super loud and that is a big
deal for people that are working
with audio files next let's jump into
xcode and we are running a benchmark
that was made for us
we compiled this project and the intel
mac mini
took 205 seconds compared to just 120
seconds on the
m1 powered mac mini now that is about a
41
difference in performance and it's much
greater than you would expect going off
of cinebench which also maxes out the
cpu
and that is because of the extra
efficiency you get with the updated
xcode program that's optimized for arm
and not only is the m1 mac mini so much
faster as you guys see by these charts
but it is silent compared to very loud
with the intel one sounding kind of like
a blow dryer
now i'm gonna stop saying the difference
in the
noise of these two machines and pretty
much all these tests this thing is just
running loud and this is silent so
just keep that in mind going forward and
now submit to photo editing using
lightroom classic now i want to point
out that lightroom has not yet been
optimized
for apple silicon it's optimized for the
intel processor
and this was the biggest concern with
this transition these legacy programs
that we need a lot of professionals need
not working at all or being super slow
now as far as the editing performance
it is identical i really can't tell a
difference and exporting it
the i7 mac mini took 3 minutes to export
50
42 megapixel raw files compared to 2
minutes
and 37 seconds so yes even though this
program
is optimized for intel the mac mini
is still faster now before we get into
video editing and then attaching the
egpu
i wanted to do one more test something
that all of us do
and that is web browsing i'm testing out
the new safari that has been updated for
arm
and we're using the web-based
speedometer to check the web browsing
performance
and here the intel mac mini scored 146
compared to
236 on the m1 powered mac
mini that is 62 better web browsing
performance so everything is really nice
and snappy getting into video editing
i'm going to start out with bruce x
which is going to test the rendering
performance of these systems
now exporting this project took only 15
seconds
on the m1 powered mac mini compared to
104
seconds that is almost seven
times better rendering performance and
this matters when you're editing
as you apply effects you're playing back
this one's going to slow down start
stuttering and glitching
whereas the new one even though it's a
lot less expensive a lot less ram it's
going to be
much smoother and that is evident with
our next test here playing back 4k
footage with color grading applied film
grade applied
the intel mac mini is stuttering it is
glitching up
whereas the new apple silicon one is
playing back perfectly smoothly
thanks to that much better graphics
performance
and here i guess apple wasn't over
exaggerating
as far as the performance difference
they actually understated it there is a
massive difference
for this task now what happens when we
export this project
the m1 mac mini is four times faster
taking just three minutes instead of 12
minutes
now in this test both of these were very
quiet almost
silent but there was a difference in
temperatures this one at the end of the
export
was at just 50 degrees celsius which is
insane very cool a lot of systems idle
higher than that
whereas the intel one pretty much the
whole time it was at or above 90 degrees
celsius
next i applied stabilization to a one
minute 4k
file that's h.265 and a lot of new
cameras are starting to
use this kodak and a lot of people want
smooth footage at least we do
and here the intel mac mini took 43
seconds compared to just nine seconds
on the m1 it is crazy to think that a
one minute clip could be stabilized
in just nine seconds that is getting
close
to my mac pro it's absolutely crazy
and now let's jump into the much more
difficult tests
i'm going to start out with canon raw
this is c-log
10-bit 422 footage that is super hard to
play back on
pretty much anything other than these
new m1 powered macs
as you guys could see in the timeline
the m1 powered mac
plays it back perfectly smoothly
compared to a stuttery mess
on the mac mini and not only on the mac
mini even on my mac
pro which costs fifteen thousand dollars
i went ahead and exported a five minute
project and this is without any color
grading or luts
which would make it even tougher on this
week graphics chip
and the m1 powered mac mini was close to
seven
times faster three minutes compared to
over
20. that is incredible now most people
have to transcode this footage
to be able to edit it smoothly and then
it will work fine if you're giving this
mac mini
prores file so i went ahead and
transcoded a one minute clip
and here the m1 mac mini took just
26 seconds compared to three minutes
on the intel base system so that is a
massive
difference in time now of course you're
gonna have more than one minute of
footage you're gonna transcode
so if we bump this up to 30 minutes of
footage the i7 will take an
hour and 30 minutes compared to just 13
minutes
on the m1 powered mac mini now just to
give you guys a little bit of
perspective
my 15 000 mac pro that takes 30 minutes
to transcode 30 minutes of footage
one to one this is three to one an hour
and a half for 30 minutes of footage
and this is i don't even know what one
to three i guess maybe
uh pretty much two two and a half three
times faster than my mac pro at
transcoding this footage
i mean if i'm somebody that's working
with this footage and you have an
imac a mac pro whatever i would just buy
one of these
the base model and just to transcode
this footage it's going to save you that
much time
if you're a professional and now jump
into raw video editing
with some red 4.5 k raw now as far as
playback both of these systems don't
play it back
perfectly but the m1 powered mac mini
does
way way better you guys could see the
difference here and if we export a five
minute project that is color graded
the difference is massive 12 minutes and
50 seconds for the m1 mac mini
compared to 39 minutes
with the i7 mac mini
absolutely incredible difference there
and now it is time
to take out the egpu and see
what kind of performance we get when we
are no longer
limited by this graphics card a lot of
people love the mac mini
to use it with any gpu get great
graphics performance
have better cooling accessible for that
cpu
so the cpu is cooled using the internal
cooling of course the graphics card has
its own cooling and extra fans in the
enclosure
let's start out by talking about the
difference in prices now i'm using the
razer core which is 300 bucks
and the 5700 xt which is about 400 bucks
maybe 450. so if we take a look at the
prices
and make sure everything is matched up
as best as we can we're comparing a
system that is eleven hundred dollars
for the m1 powered mac mini
compared to 2250
for the i7 with the egpu if you go ahead
and you upgrade the ram
yourself and then you don't have 10
gigabit ethernet let's start out by
comparing the raw
graphics performance using geekbench 5
and here you can see that adding that
egpu with the 5700 xt
made the intel mac mini about 12 times
faster
than using the integrated graphics the
massive difference in performance
and with that it's close to three times
more powerful in terms of graphics
compared to apple's 8 core gpu in the
new
apple silicon mac mini so that's a huge
difference in performance with that said
i want to mention
two things first off e-gpus are
loud unless you buy the much more
expensive blackmagic ones
which i think they discontinued now this
thing is running really loud compared to
silent
and with that the graph performance
doesn't always equate
to actual professional performance and
applications because there's different
bottlenecking which is going to make
this
very interesting now if you're into
gaming the egpu scored 194.7 frames per
second in gfx bench
compared to 78 so that's roughly two and
a half times better
gaming performance under metal that's a
pretty massive difference
now as far as logic performance there is
really no difference because that's all
cpu based
and the same thing goes for xcode
there's no difference
adding that egpu now one area where
there is a difference that i wasn't
expecting
is photo editing at least when you're
rendering these really large
42 megapixel images instead of taking
three minutes it took us two minutes and
44 seconds with the egpu so the
difference was minimal but it is there
and with that said the m1 powered mac
mini was still faster at 2 minutes and
37
seconds now i got to mention two things
again one this has 16 gigs of ram
compared to 64. and we know that
lightroom
loves ram from our previous tests and
along with that
this application is optimized for intel
max
not apple powered mac so it's gonna be
very interesting once it's optimized
now let's jump into video editing and
this is going to
blow your mind for multiple reasons
let's start out with bruce x which is
all graphics based for rendering all
your effects and color grading and
everything else
and instead of taking 104 seconds
with a gpu it took just 14 seconds
that's a massive difference
with that said the mac mini took 15
seconds
one second longer now what's going to
blow your mind
is that not only is this silent compared
to a super loud external graphics card
unit
but this mac mini with the m1 graphics 8
core chip
was running only 5.6 watts of power
that's all that needed
to do this task in 15 seconds 5.6 watts
the egpu uses over 200 watts of power
in a windows pc it's actually 275 watts
i don't know exactly what it is on a mac
but definitely over 200 watts of power
compared to 5.6 that is just
insane now of course you do have to keep
in mind that there are bottlenecks using
an external graphics card unit over
thunderbolt 3.
if i took the same graphics card and put
into my mac pro
that would take 8 seconds instead of 14.
so we are losing
quite a bit of performance having this
card be in the egpu
and based on your task in some cases
there's less difference in some cases
there's more of a difference
in this case this is the most
performance loss that you'll get when
we're maxing out the graphics card so
now
let's jump into 4k video editing and as
you guys saw
before the mac mini couldn't play back
4k footage with some
color grading done with the egpu it is
playing it back perfectly
and the mac mini with the m1 chip can
also play it back perfectly without
needing that unit
now let's go ahead and export this five
minute project again
and here instead of taking 12 minutes it
took just four minutes and 21 seconds so
that's getting close to three times
better performance but that is still not
touching
the three minutes in six seconds that we
got with the m1 powered mac mini now of
course
this is fairly easy footage this is what
most people on youtube are working with
but what about for professionals that
are working with much tougher footage
so here is that same 10-bit hevc footage
from the new canon cameras
and as you can see even with the egpu
the intel powered mac mini is not
playing it back smoothly
like the apple silicon mac mini is and
that is because
all these new graphics cards including
the brand new 3080s
and the 6080 series or the 6000 series
from amd
none of them have special decoding for
this new type of
footage that canon is using whereas the
mac mini
does and that's why i can play it back
super smoothly
now when i go ahead and export this
footage instead of taking over
20 minutes when we add the egpu it took
10 minutes and 55 seconds
still more than three times slower than
the three minutes
with the m1 powered mac mini that's way
less
expensive and silent now i also wanted
to test
canon raw that's from the c200 c300
those kind of cameras
but unfortunately it's not yet working
on these new mac mini
so i wasn't able to test it but once
again i could test out the red raw
and the 4.5 k red raw now with the egpu
it plays back smoother than the mac mini
instead of worse
but it's still not perfect they're a lot
more close now and then when we go ahead
and export
a five minute graded project instead of
taking 39 minutes
it took only nine minutes and 35 seconds
with the egpu
and for the first time ever the i7
mac mini with any gpu was faster than
this
m1 powered mac mini that cost me 900
and this one took 12 minutes so we're
starting to see a difference
there and even there it's not really
worth paying that extra money
and dealing with all these extras to get
that better performance at least in my
opinion now i want to take this a step
further
and take a look at ak footage on an ak
timeline here in final cut and as you
guys could see
neither of these machines are playing it
back perfectly even with the gpu
but the egpu mac mini is a little bit
smoother
and then i went ahead and i exported
this not to 4k
h364 but to 8k prores
and the difference was only two and a
half
minutes here wow i was expecting to see
a massive difference and there wasn't
so there you guys go i am just
absolutely blown away
because of how fast this runs for the
price
and the noise and the heat it is
incredible and for most people
it is still better just to get one of
these instead of getting one of these
external graphics card units with their
old mac mini so if you're somebody that
has an old one you're contemplating
should i just sell it and buy a new one
or should i add it on egpu
there you guys go let me know your
thoughts down in the comment section
below
now i will mention a couple other
differences
the intel powered mac mini once again
you can have 10 gigabit ethernet
you also have four thunderbolt 3 ports
so you can connect
more devices and along with that you can
connect more displays
the the new m1 powered mac minis you're
only at 16 gigs of ram
which is actually roughly 32 gigabytes
performance wise
from my testing if you're comparing it
to an intel based system
and you can have two external displays
one hdmi and one thunderbolt
you cannot have 10 gigabit ethernet and
so
those are some limitations with this
system i do expect apple to make
a higher end one to replace the six core
model that's gonna have four
thunderbolt three or and usb4 ports and
10 gigabit either an
option to match it up and then i'll have
even better graphics and cpu performance
that is going to be absolutely insane
alright guys
let me know your thoughts once again
down in the comment section
and if you want to see this mac mini go
head to head against my mac pro
click that circle above enables
notifications below you guys can see a
couple other great videos right over
there
i have all the links linked in the video
description to the ram egpu this mac
mini thanks for watching so max and i'll
see you in the next video
you